a grim task for John Ellis from the
canal and River trust removing dead fish
from the Grand Union Canal near solihull
oxygen pumps installed here weren't
enough to save them it's just one
incident of dozens across the country
over the past few weeks and evidence of
the impact of temperatures that the Met
Office has confirmed delivered the UK's
hottest June on record it's been an
unprecedented month what we're seeing is
dissolved oxygen levels in the water
that are so low that they can't support
fish life
and we think issues almost certainly
caused by the ever increasing
temperatures that we're seeing it's
damaging our Wildlife because not only
the fish themselves but the the birds
that and mammals that rely on fish your
herons your Kingfishers your Greaves and
your otters will all suffer if we don't
have healthy fish populations in our
waterways Met Office data shows that
June temperatures have increased over
the decades this Jagged line shows June
extremes here are the previous high
points in 1940 1976 and now of course
2023 but this dotted line shows the
trend in average temperatures for the
months and over the last 40 years in
particular you can see it's been going
up it reflects a more General Trend all
10 of the UK's warmest years on record
happened in the last two decades and
2022 was the hottest of them all with
the average year-round temperature above
10 degrees Celsius for the first time
ever
scientists warn that these conditions
Bear the Fingerprints of climate change
in the atmosphere and in the global
weather patterns we have natural
variability so there's a natural
phenomenon that's always occurs year on
year
what's different is the background state
of the warming climate that in some
senses give that turbo boost to that
natural variability
the Ripple effects of a hot start to
Summer have been widespread from new
hose pipe bands in Kent and Sussex
to this a few weeks ago in the Scottish
Highlands dry vegetation fueling
wildfire
hotter drier summers in the UK Pleasant
for many but also a sign of how our
world is changing Hannah Thomas Peter
Sky News